what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 5 of the JavaScript basics tutorial
in this tutorial we are going to be
getting into object-oriented programming
so object-oriented programming is a
specific programming paradigm and with
JavaScript there's actually many
programming paradigms it's a
multi-paradigm programming language so
you can do things also like functional
programming and others I'm just gonna do
object-oriented programming it makes the
most sense to me I've tried functional
programming I just can't
so in functional programming is not to
be confused with writing functions like
pretty much everything we've done up to
this point is script so we write some
variables we're using functions just to
make our lives easier but we're not
doing like functional programming here
so anyway so why might we want to use
one of the paradigms so with anything
just like with editors and programming
languages and significant others you
want to try a few and go with the one
that you like the best so the one that
everybody else likes isn't necessarily
the one for you
so with object-oriented programming or
any of these other ones the reason why
we want to start doing this is it's in
general we want to be able to abstract
things out and build on top of things so
in the case of blob here in order for us
to have let's say we like in in my case
I want to have many blobs ok this is
fine for the one blob but when it comes
time where we want to have maybe 10 15
30 blobs this becomes a lot more
challenging because now we you know we
could assign some sort of what do they
call it and I think it's called object
literal in JavaScript so it's like a
dictionary in Python but it's like a key
to value representation you know you you
could do something like that and track
them but it's gonna be so messy and
silly for what we actually want to do so
with object or in the programming we
define this object and this object has
attributes and methods and the
attributes are like descriptions right
like like what's the size of the blob
where's the blob located what's its
color those would be the attributes and
then a method might be mu
okay so doing things right that's what
we're gonna use methods for so that's
object-oriented programming and then
basically we just define this blob
object and then we create variables that
are a blob object and then it just
becomes so much more simple to expand
and grow and build on top of this blob
object and manage many blobs this way
I'm not saying it can't be done purely
with writing functions the way we've
done it I can think of a few ways to do
it it's just probably not the best way
and then also if you make classes and
stuff your code just becomes much more
usable either by yourself in the future
or for others okay shut the heck up
let's go
somebody will post a timestamp tutorial
starts at 15 minutes in okay so so I'm
actually gonna leave the function here
for now just because we're gonna
copypasta some of these things so to
start our definition of our class we
literally just say class and then we say
the class name of what it is and then
it's some curly doodads and then we're
good to go
now the class is going to contain most
of the lines will be methods most likely
but the first method is called your
construct construct or method now this
is the one that if when you define aver
you define your object if you wanted to
be a little past certain values these
are where you're gonna pass them so
you'll notice I didn't put you know
parentheses here it's not because I
forgot it's because actually they go
here so in your constructor method we're
gonna pass color in size and then the
code to the method so it looks a lot
like a function now the only big
difference is basically with this
constructor method anytime you define a
blob object the constructor method will
be run so in this case anything we put
in here is going to be run now generally
what you actually put in here are the
attributes so we're gonna have the
attributes like X and well I don't know
why I didn't in anyway X
and why and color in size these are the
things that are gonna go in here now in
order to make these attributes
accessible across the entire objects we
actually lead them with a this I don't
it's not a key word I don't think I'm
not really sure what to call this word
some JavaScript expert that's watching
these tutorials for some reason can
comment below anyway
we lead them with this and it just
refers to this object so we're just
gonna say this dot X this dot y this dot
color and this dot the AWS this dot size
it's like self in Python so now we're
going to say is this dot x equals and in
this case we're just going to start
these randomly so I'm gonna say math dot
random which is just a built in and now
math dot random generates a random a
pseudo random number between 0 and 1 so
we can treat that like it's a percentage
and just say math dot random times
canvas dot width
boom done and then we're gonna do the
exact same thing with Y except rather
than the width that would be the height
then this dot color is equal to the
color that got passed in those
parameters this dot size same story
there let's do our semicolons because
we're good little JavaScript errs so now
what we want to do is we're gonna define
the X change in Y change so we're gonna
say this dot X change equals we'll say 1
for now this not Y change is also equal
to 1 great I think at that point we've
got all of the initial methods that we
want
I'm sorry huh and this all attributes
that we want and now we're gonna write
our methods so coming down here I kind
of want to point out older so sometimes
I'll save it for the end hopefully in
the end I'll remember so I'll probably
finish this tutorial and at the end I'm
gonna bring up how old ooh
old classes were defined so sticker
if you want to look at that because if
the problem is with JavaScript there's
so much like outdated JavaScript that
just keeps getting recycled and I'm sure
that somewhere in here I'm making that
sin as well I'm doing my best to like
write the new es6 stuff but i'm sure i'm
screwing that up so anyway so call me
out on it if I do but anyway I will show
that at the end how you might see other
people using classes because it's
completely it looks different than this
you'd be like wait what's this
so anyway moving along the next regular
method that we're gonna make is the move
method and move will do not take any
parameters for now but later it might
and in fact let me just zoom in a little
bit so everybody can see hopefully
that's better
can everybody in the back see that okay
so now so so move is basically gonna be
this code here so actually I'm just
gonna cut that BOP on up here pasta that
fix the indenting oh no shouldn't that
oh dear I thought you could do closing
or opening square brackets and that
would shift back over anyway I don't
know okay hmm so now to access this
value this is why we use this so now we
can actually even though these are what
appear to be two totally separate
methods there are men separate methods
in the st. of the same object so or the
same class so we can actually reference
them but ins from inside different
methods so actually I just need to say
this dot X this dot X change this dot X
and then we're just going to continue
doing that here here in here this is
super error-prone but I think we'll make
it
boom cool so now we have our move method
completed so now the next thing my dog
is currently dreaming and I think he's
barking at things sorry uh so we're
gonna come down here and I'm actually an
add another method called draw and I'm a
little undecided as where whether draw
should actually go inside of here or not
we might actually make draw a separate
thing entirely and maybe make it put it
just in a function or something like
that to draw all the blob objects the
blob Dex but I'm gonna put it in here
for now
just because I want more than one method
honestly yeah so to do this we're gonna
copy everything except for clear rekt
because we don't want every time we draw
any blob we don't want to clear that
entire canvas so pasta that up in there
and in this case this would be this dot
X this dot Y this would be this dot size
and then this would be this dot color
and at this point we're actually done
with the blob function so I'm gonna
delete the blob function and in fact I'm
gonna delete set interval as well so
we're not gonna use that we will use
that in the future but for now we don't
need that and instead what I would like
to do is interact with our blob jecht
so first of all to define this it's it's
kind of like a data type so I don't
think we've done arrays yet I can't
remember but anytime you make this new
object it will be like variable like let
or Const the name of it and then it's a
new object type right and then you pass
the parameters so for us that's Const
and then I'm gonna call this new blob so
that's just the variable name and that's
equal to a new blob object and then the
parameters we're gonna pass are green
and 25 because
is that's the color and the signs that
we want so if we come up here remember
that was passed through the constructor
method so now I'm just going to say a
new blob dot draw and that should draw
it to our page because we've defined the
canvas so let's go ahead and run this
see if we hit any errors hmm nope
there's our bob beautiful so the next
thing I just we can actually open up the
console so it's usually like f12 and
then you go into console now this is
unbearably tiny I wish I could make this
larger for everybody but I don't think
if I scroll in I don't think that does
anything yeah let's see if there's a
quick font size here tab sighs keep
onions no oh dear lovely I'm on a VPS I
really wish there was a font size but
there's not so just listen and follow
along so what we're gonna do is is so
we've drawn it now what we can do is
actually interact with it in the console
even you could do this in your code as
well but we just reference that new blob
so it's all lowercase except for the
bean blob dot and then we can do move
semicolon enter that blob is moved now
we could actually draw it so new capital
B blob dot draw open and closed
parenthesis semicolon boom you should
have seen an update on my page but
probably on yours as well so now we can
just like up arrow twice up arrow twice
and just keep doing that and we can see
that the blob is slowly moving and
that's how we're interacting with it in
the console so pretty cool now I think
that's probably everything I want to
cover for before we get into making mini
blobs because the whole reason we were
doing this is so we could have many
blobs but an ordinary have many blobs we
need to cover for loops and somehow pro
tutorials centex guy has gotten us into
object
programming in a basic series before for
loops huh good job so we need to use for
loops and that's a different concept and
I don't really feel like covering that
here so I still have I still want to
show you guys old classes and I'm gonna
do that
uno momento but first shot to my most
recent channel members backwards are and
Michael
Michelle Berardi I don't know tell me in
the comments is that Michael or Michelle
if you're watching ok so what I'd like
to do now is just talk for a moment
about how the old classes looked cuz
they're kind of silly so so in the past
it would be something like this it would
be like function blob I might be
screwing some of this up but it was
basically like this and then you would
have your init method and they would
just call it in it and actually I want
to say it was actually an embedded
function so it'll be like function init
and then some stuff and then sometimes
people would just end it with open and
close parentheses and that would run it
immediately but then other times you
would see people would call init right
after their init method I don't think
that was ever actually object-oriented
programming but they would also use this
the this keyword or I'm sorry I mean it
was object on your program but I don't
really know on the back end how
JavaScript actually ran things but just
so you know you might see something like
this I know I've seen it around I
promise I see this more often than I see
the classes and that seems to be true
with a lot of es6 like I don't I don't
know why is it the case that like like
the first time I saw let being used and
this I'm pretty sure was when I started
using tensorflow j/s and so I I don't
know I don't know why it's it's almost
like I thought the difference between
Python 2 and 3
that like chasm was bad but it seems
like this chasm is worse because you got
both people using it and there's no like
update that forces anybody to use one or
the other
I don't know anyways yeah super
confusing for someone like me first
coming into here and it's like wait
which what do I use and like if you
google how to do object or any
programming in JavaScript you're often
gonna find not this way you're gonna
find the old way so anyway if you ever
do Google stuff with JavaScript I highly
recommend ending it with es6 anyways
goodbye dog is leaving so I guess that's
the end of the tutorial people are
leaving the class so thanks for watching
everybody in the next tutorial we will
cover a couple of for loops and just
kind of iterating over simple objects
making many blobs and just making a
really satisfying canvas of blobs just
bounce and run so stay tuned for that
I'll see you there